mise dans le cadre d'une enquête ouverte
à la fois sur les comptes de la campagne
présidentielle de jean luc mélenchon est
sur une affaire d'emplois présumés
fictifs à la france un soumise au
parlement européen
la réaction de jean luc mélenchon a été
assez vives cette d'alexis corbières un
de ses proches le député de
seine-saint-denis aussi regarder ces
images avec un conseil préalable
éloignez les enfants du post c'est du
brutal en quoi qui vous a donné cet
ordre
je suis aux parlementaires vous ne
touchez pas je ne sais pas nous ne
sommes pas des voyous des bandits allez
faire votre métier de policier
un procureur tout cela est il bien
raisonnable
maintenant parce que je me souviens que
que monsieur melanson avait critiqué les
les gens de droite d'extrême droite
c'est-à-dire les fillonnistes ou
lepénistes et lorsqu'ils avaient été
eux-mêmes
perquisitionné lorsque leurs locaux
avaient été personae et mélenchon je me
souviens encore son discours avait dit
mais enfin quels sont ces gens qui osent
s'opposer à la justice bon il ya une
perquisition sur des emplois fictifs
dans le voilà et donc il faut il faut
respecter la justice qui peut pas y
avoir deux poids deux mesures c'est à
dire qu'il peut pas y avoir des
perquisitions que pour les hommes
politiques de droite ou de droite
radicale et pas de perquisition pour la
france
insoumise je crois que là je ça
m'intéresse de voir qu'on faisait né le
défendre parce que jusque là c'était un
peu difficile je ne vois pas comment
monsieur béland sow peut se défendre il
a payé il y là il a perdu perdu ses
nerfs et alors à tout prendre
effectivement je vous concède tous les
trois que c'est vrai emmanuel macron
s'était pas charles de gaulle hier soir
on est de le suivre on n'est pas
vraiment l'avouer n'est pas aussi mais
on n'a jamais mais si vous voulez si
l'anglais là je vois un homme politique
qui a quand même un peu perdu ses nerfs
et à tout prendre entre mélenchon et
macro je choisis macro france branco la
parole est à la défense et à l'avocat de
jean-luc mélenchon
écoutez moi je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
éléments sur la question des
perquisitions des forces politiques
c'est toujours un sujet très délicat
surtout ans cadre dans quatre
préliminaire c'est à dire qu'elles
soient ordonnées par le procureur avec
l'autorisation du juge des libertés des
tensions c'est à dire par quelqu'un qui
est statutairement dépendant du
gouvernement et qui prend ses
instructions de celui ci c'est pas la
même chose qu'une perquisition ordonnée
par un juge d'instruction qui est lui
statutairement indépendants et dont on
ne peut pas soupçonner qu'il y ait des
influences ou non et dans cette attaque
la présentant du procureur présent il
cessa exactement et c'est pour ça aussi
que le syndicat de la magistrature n'a
pas condamné l'action de mélenchon et au
contraire a appelé une réforme
constitutionnelle afin de lever toute
possibilité de doute ou d'incertitude
dans ce cadre dans ce cadre là afin de
s'assurer qu'en effet on puisse pas
accuser deux façons soit mensongère soit
différemment tout soit basé sur des
faits réels
les policiers et les procureurs de faire
leur travail sur ordre politique célèbre
pour son mur des con way et qui est
quand même le principal syndicat de la
magistrature donc aussi alors qu'ils
défendent pas nommé cercle des femmes
nobles devoirs du sm caen et voilà un
peu pâli c'est ce que j'ai à dire c'est
pourquoi pour par exemple par exemple il
y avait parmi les coups y avait un type
dont la dans la pauvre fille avait
assassiné dans le fait qu'il s'agit pas
de là de dire que le syndicaliste raturé
bon pas mais c'est quand même un
représentant d'une partie de l'autorité
judiciaire c'est tout ce que je veux
dire l'autorité judiciaire qui a été
remise en question par mulhausen said de
goût oui oui tout à fait et mais je vois
pas ce que ça change et sur le sur la
question des perquisitions c'est-à-dire
de 15 perquisitions simultanées qui ont
fait saisir l'ensemble des appareils de
communication de production
d'information de la france insoumise et
de ses principaux dirigeants il faut
quand même voir ce que ça fait pour un
parti politique d'opposition en effet le
matin d'un remaniement en termes de
déstabilisation de la vie politique
française
tout cela pour une affaire dont je
rappelle quand même qu'il s'agit de
savoir si les collaborateurs
parlementaires européens ont été
utilisés à bruxelles ou à paris mais au
service quand même de l'action politique
de la france un soulagement exactement
et on en avait parlé ici dans des bals
et apprend là j'avais dit attention
c'est quand même pas une affaire qui me
semblent de premier ordre sur le front
national marine le pen ou pour françois
bayrou qui avait quitté le gouvernement
dans une eau cause d' enquête
préliminaire sur le même c'est sur le
oui avec une peau de oui à une enquête
printers et raison j'ai à dire une mise
en examen mais non il n'y a pas de mise
en examen
donc là dessus il faut quand même mettre
en proportion les différents éléments et
ensuite après il ya quelque chose qui
est en effet très angoissante dans cette
vidéo c'est qu'on a une incarnation
d'une partie de la souveraineté
nationale sert des députés qui sont en
conflit direct avec l'autorité autorités
républicaines qui est la force de police
et derrière les procureurs et on sent
qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne fonctionne
plus qui se dérèglent c'est à dire dans
le climat actuel en france quand on se
retrouve dans une situation avec elle
parce que la france a soumises s'est pas
non plus enfin vous voyez bien à un
moment quand mélenchon dit je suis la
république vous ne touchez pas je suis
il a un respect fondamental d'un
scission république s'est ancré en lui
je pense qu'il est très sincère et donc
quand on a des personnes qui
représentent des forces qui sont
républicaines fondamentalement et qui se
trouve dans une stratégie de tension
qu'elle soit voulue ou pas avec
l'incarnation de la force
le police et la force publique on se dit
il ya quand même quelque chose qui est
en train de se dégrader trop rapidement
dans ce pays il faut s'interroger sur
les sources de cette violence qui en
train de monter à une vitesse qui est
vraiment inquiétant que moi en tant que
citoyen je ressens de l'inquiétude des
mémés doublé c'est à dire nos jeux et je
vois très bien ce que c'est pas mais
l'argent qui vous fait peur c'est aussi
face à messi
certaines de ces doubles cette
confrontation violente mais vraiment est
vraiment temps que parfois la nuit porte
conseil ou en tout cas le permet de ceux
de se calmer mais ça n'a pas du tout été
le cas puisque jean luc mélenchon était
invité ce matin de notre confrère jean
jacques bourdin sur rmc
et il en a remis une louche mélenchon
pas content épisode 2 à 7 heures
d'effort mais oui police on ouvre la
porte on vous montre le truc
huit personnes chez moi dont certains
sont armés avec des gilets pare-balles
des fois que je sais pas quoi je les
adresse avec mon crayon tout ça est
ridicule
il suffisait de me demander quoi
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent me demandez
vous savez ce qui se passe monsieur
bourdin ya rien dans le dossier onu
perquisitionnent comme si on était une
bande de voleurs dans tout le pays c'est
pas normal
donc j'ai le droit de le dire j'ai le
droit de me fâcher je suis un
méditerranéen je bouge beaucoup les bras
et vous aussi
et les yeux et le reste et je me fâche
ouais je dois reconnaître que sans être
un mélenchonistes pur sucre
je comprends assez 7 cette réaction à ce
que la police s'en fait pas trop s qu'il
n'y a pas une espèce de de mise en scène
las de tout le monde mais c'est un peu a
toujours un théâtre d'ombrés la
politique
moi je suis je pense que quand même les
questions politiques ne devraient pas
être laissée à l'appréciation du parquet
quand même fondamentalement ça pose un
problème je rappelle que la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme 10
touches nous rappelle toujours te
parquet n'est pas indépendant dans ses
affaires il devrait y avoir
systématiquement un juge d'instruction
car on touche à quelque chose de trop
sensible et la liste des à dison d'un
certain nombre d'adversaires politiques
qui ont des ennuis avec le parquet je
dis bien s'allonge un petit peu oui
françois fillon ayant été un des
exemples emblématiques et mise en pause
qui de signer chez lui aussi mis en
cause je vous rappelle par le met à la
belote et perkins chéri parce que j'en
ai senti seul au monde
françois fillon n'a été aussi basse que
j je trouve dans ces affaires il devrait
y avoir peut-être vous savez ce que dit
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
que on me regarde toujours elle dit la
femme de césar ne doit pas être
soupçonnée c'est à dire il faut qu'il y
ait une apparence d'indépendance je met
pas du tout en cause des procureurs mais
il doit y avoir toutes les apparences
d'indépendance
ce qui n'est pas le cas en france je
suis là quand même raison mélenchon sur
un point je vous ai même donné raison
sur un point c'est effectivement
peut-être que la police et les
procureurs pourraient faire autre chose
que non baird et les hommes politiques
sur l' usage de leurs attachés
parlementaires il apporter ma valise il
n'a pas porté il était là il est à bruce
étape apparaît je pense qu'il ya
peut-être effectivement autre chose à
faire et c'est le point que j'ai aimé
dans son allocution si nous ne sommes
pas des bandits nous sommes pas des
gangsters il ya des bandits et des
gangsters
alors c'est vrai que c'est moins amusant
d'aller les chercher c'est vrai que
c'est très médiatique d'aller emmerder
quand on a un petit juge ni procureur
trois policiers un homme politique mais
il y a il ya quand même une limite et je
trouve que
la police et la justice devraient quand
même s'intéresser à des choses plus
importantes plus crucial pour la
sécurité publique que de
systématiquement cherché des noises au
premier pouvoir c'est à dire à
l'exécutif et au deuxième pouvoir
c'est-à-dire aux législatives quelques
réactions d'internautes blueberry qui
nous dit où il ne manque plus que des
répliques à la audiard façon tontons
flingueurs et c'est vrai que en tout cas
on est dans un dans un peut-être une
comédie il ya qu'elle nous dit qu aurait
dit mélenchon si le pen s'était comporté
comme lui et babineau estime que la mise
en scène vient surtout de la france
insoumise des milliers de français se
font perquisitionné et on vous a posé la
question
c'est même la question du jour sur le
figaro.fr est ce que vous êtes choqué
par la réaction et les propos de
jean-luc mélenchon
suite à ces perquisitions et vous êtes
une assez large majorité a considéré que
oui appartenez-vous à cette majorité
jean christophe bus savoir comme gérer
je pense que l'esprit de sérieux est en
train de grignoter tous les uns des
autres
c'est une vaste blague cette histoire je
ne doute pas une seconde que mélenchon
et été choqués par cette arrivée il a
considéré comme violent de huit
policiers mais toute la mise en scène
j'ai pensé à happy set lorsqu'il parlait
de napoléon dix ans le comédien tetra
gigant et mélenchon il met en scène tout
ça il et il sait très bien les codes de
la société du spectacle
il en fait des tonnes parce qu'il ce
film parce qu'il est filmée parce qu'il
sait que ça va être diffusé et il va
choquer les gens il fait la même chose
que féru fin lorsqu'il intervient
l'assemblée nationale en disant ensuite
dans un dans une petite vidéo que il a
il a parlé comme ça l'assemblée
nationale parce qu'ils considèrent le
travail législatif ne sert à rien
puisqu'ils sont pas assez nombreux pour
peser sur la vie parlementaire
donc c'est une tribune et bien voilà
mélenchon hier il a une tribune
formidable avec en plus les policiers
face à lui donc il se donner le beau
rôle
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale
était beaucoup moins virulent et pour
cause que je crois qu'ils croient pas
une seconde à ce qu'il dit hier il fait
des spectacles d'une tribu il sait qu'il
ya plein de gens qui vont se sentir
heurté mais je il n'est pas sincère
lorsqu'il dit ma personne et sacré juan
branco ma personne et sans cris est
sacrée il sait très bien que il est le
premier à dire que les députés les
sénateurs les ministres ne sont pas au
dessus des lois qu'il faut pouvoir
révoquer les députés lorsqu'ils se
comporte mal en lui il pense
qu'il est innocent qui a pas de raison
de faire ça mais la justice suit son
cours
une perquisition comme elle en a le
droit lui la met en scène mais il n'est
pas au dessous des lois il n'est pas une
personne sacrée
c'est faux et c'est très bien que c'est
faux quelqu'un qui admire robespierre
qui a envoyé à la guillotine des députés
qui étaient pas aussi douanes en plus on
sait très bien dans tout ça est un jeu
est une mascarade de la part de
mélenchon moi je pense que là vous vous
faites et je pense que je pense
sincèrement je pense que de ce que je
connais du personnage pour l'avoir un
peu fréquentées d'une part il ya la
question là par exemple le parquet qui a
remis une couche aujourd'hui en
maintenant ou en ouvrant une procédure
pour menaces et violences serre contre
et là on est parti pour pour répondre
aux il a bien pu procéder aux basques
l'impasse corbières et mélenchon eux
mêmes ont porté plainte pour viol en
ogre wheel au magistrat vient c'est pour
faire match nul le parquet c'est facile
mais bon au moins nous derrière on doit
travailler pour un deux ans pour essayer
de montrer avec une possibilité de deux
ordres de peine de prison quand même
ferme à ce sujet donc je pense que là
c'était franchement déplacé comme geste
mais ça c'est sur la question
procédurale qui fait qu' ils ont quand
même conscience du fait qu'il y a un
enjeu mais sur cette phrase très
importante qui prononce à ce moment là
et je pense qu'elle vient des entrailles
allait pas préparé ses idées un moment
aux policiers la république c'est moi et
voyant bien le l'historicité dans lequel
s'inscrit cette parole évidemment c'est
un rapport direct avec la phrase de
louis xiv d'état c'est moi et c'est
justement une sorte de fusion de deux
traditions historiques françaises qui
est justement le républicanisme que vous
pensez auxquelles vous pensez qu'il est
adhérent forcené mais non c'est
mélenchon qui est féru d'histoire est en
train d'essayer de construire des
syncrétismes qui fut son trait vème
république finalement et là dessus et là
dessus quand on dit la république c'est
moi il est en train justement du jeu
compense de dire quelque chose auquel il
croit fondamentalement c'est à dire que
la position qu'il occupe à cet instant
dans l'espace public fait que la justice
et la police ne devrait pas agir sur lui
et puis ton âme politique et chez n'a
pas droit de voler n'a pas le droit de
mentir n'a pas le droit de tuer et
appartements la justice ces personnes
que c'est le cas elle est en droit de
faire ça jusqu'à 60 ans quel bonheur par
une balle procure ensuite valoir qu il
ne prétend pas l'être
les grands-parents dû utiliser le
montant auquel il apporte en tant que
joueur et en tant que sion sa fonction
il est sacré pas sa personne
premièrement et deuxièmement il y avait
quand même un juge de l'application des
peines qui était juste à liberté
d'édition il a autorisé déçu car je
complète je trouve aussi que la réaction
est excessive qu'elle soit spontanée ou
pas les telle somme excessive
justement j'ai pensé un peu
l'arrestation de danton oui c'est un
petit peu c'est un petit peu ça la
protestation devant ce qui lui arrive on
a présenté au comité de salut public
vient l'arrêter et qu'on va envoyer
mélenchon à la guillotine
mais ce qui en dit long aussi sur sa
culture politique qui moi je entre nous
maquiller traits un peu si c'était lui
qui avait les manettes du pouvoir voilà
et sae et notamment dans les pays qu'il
admire et qu'ils sont pas des modèles
d'état de droit c'est moi qu'on comme
leurs aînés nous restons sur une note
positive et consensuelle jean luc
mélenchon croit au sacré et se réfère à
louis xiv qui a mandat est fait de bois
de nouvelles mais ça ça n'est qu'un
point de vue on passe à un autre sujet
beaucoup moins drôle malheureusement la
sphère cachot guy du nom de ce
journaliste saoudien opposants au
pouvoir qui a disparu au début du mois
dans le consulat d'arabie saoudite à
istanbul il on soupçonne très fortement
le pouvoir saoudien de l'avoir tuée puis
même peut-être coupé en morceaux mais on
n'a pas de certitudes et ce qu'on nous
cache des choses dans ce dossier renaud
girard vous qu'il connaissait bien
à l'évidence je connais pas que choi
mais je connais bien les biens dossier
et il est évident qu'on nous cache des
choses est évident que les saoudiens
commencer par eux mêmes donc elle des
choses pourquoi le jour où qu'elles
soient liées disparaît il envoie deux
avions privés à istanbul avec 15
l'équipe de 15 membres dont des membres
des services secrets et un médecin
légiste
voilà c'est pas hasard ils sont
incapables de dire ce qui est devenu ce
pauvre jamal